his stories one of my favorites when I
was covering the league and now he's
covering the league alongside everybody
at the NFL Media Group when he's on NFL
Total Access every night at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern Time third-round pick in the
2007 draft pride of San Jose State Green
Bay Super Bowl champion played with the
Raiders also good to see you James Jones
I'm so I just want to get into this real
quick your your story playing football
did football save your Oh ask you think
absolutely man that was my main
motivation growing up man that's you
know a lot of people may not know my
story but growing up homeless for the
first 15 years of my life in and out of
homeless shelters schlep on park benches
football was was always that was sob and
whenever I got on the football field it
was always that was all the problems
outside outside of football didn't
matter and you know a lot of my coaches
would tell me man that you got the
ability to play in the National Football
League and I knew that could be a way to
meet for me to get my mom out the
situation so it was always my main
motivation man and you know in 2007 when
I got drafted in the third round man
everybody went crazy man and I tell
people all the time there's no greater
feeling and working extremely hard for
something you know what I mean dreaming
about it and then it finally comes so
who gave you the shock who gave you the
shot to get off a park bench and start
playing football Jim well my coach
Marion Lauria he came and he donated a
meal to the homeless shelter and I was
probably about seven years old and he's
seen me outside playing football
wouldn't eaten or nothing I'm just
outside throwing the ball up and he came
up to me talking to me for a little bit
like man you want to play football this
and then I'm like yeah I would love to
play football man but my mom don't got
the money and all that so you know I
can't play right now and he was like
well I'm the coach for the Santa Teresa
Bulldogs and I want you to be on my team
and he talked to my mom he was like look
we're gonna pay for this kid to play
you're gonna be on our team and he paid
for my whole Pop Warner career for me to
play man and and it took off from there
man I used to sleep at his house stay at
his house and all that good stuff man he
feed me and all that stuff so you know
he was the main one man I gave me my
first shot James Jones here in the Rich
Eisen show so what was it like for you
to win a Super Bowl
what was that like oh man it was it was
dream come true and it's crazy because
I'm not a big crier you know like I'm
not I'm not a big crier bleh
when the clock struck zero and I seen
the confetti coming down I mean I
couldn't hold my tears back I just
started crying you know what I mean I
dropped to one knee I just started
crying and I'm sitting there like I'm
not crying because of the game like we
won but you know all this stuff started
kicking in like the journey that I've
been through everything that I faced and
I'm sitting here the biggest game in the
world I'm a Superbowl champion I'm the
best in the world now can't no team say
they better than us and just thinking
about everything I've been through man
the tears just started coming down man
and I was just telling my man in the bag
man there's no greater feeling than
winning the Superbowl yeah TJ Jefferson
who's oh who was chatting with you for
our social media accounts I can't wait
to see the chat that you had with him
later on we post it later on and now
you're you're you're proving successful
in that difficult transition period of
playing and now you're part of the NFL
me breaking stories know like Aaron
Rodgers contract NFL Network's James
Jones by the way was the one who wrote
that one that had have been an
interesting day for you it was Aaron
Rodgers had called me today before and
he was like JJ get ready it's about to
go down and I'm I'm at home scrambling
like it's going down where he like no no
not tomorrow tomorrow is probably gonna
go down tomorrow so I'm like okay so my
wife had had the tweet all done all
right okay oh I've had the tweet all
done and ready already so all we needed
was numbers and years I'm like this you
know I mean I'm not finna getting a
whole breakdown like Ian and those guys
I'm like just give me numbers and years
you know and I'll have what I'm gonna
say in there so I'm actually at the gym
working out and he calls me and now
right Aaron calls me and he's like JJ's
is about to go down you know so then
knowing that you're gonna tweet him yeah
he's giving you the school yes he's
giving me the schools like I'm in here
right now it's about to go down are you
ready what do you need and I'm like all
right just give me the numbers and the
years and you know
guaranties so he started giving me all
that my wife's trying to tweak the
tweeted out but her phone is blowing up
people calling her and all that so she's
hanging up people calling me texting me
like man we're hearing this is stressful
Oh
retire from breaking stories and then
finally we got the numbers from air and
we tweeted it out man he was juiced that
I was able to break it and I mean it was
it was just it was it was unbelievable
that but at the same time I'm like damn
this is a stressful job I can't do this
trying to get your tweet out there
before everybody and everybody got their
own little insiders and we're in there
and and little connections I'm like this
stressful well I mean so knowing and so
Aaron gave you a good teammate gave you
the scoop in your next career I love
that story so what do you think about
this week his readiness for this week
Jim um his readiness I don't know how
ready he's gonna be but I do know me
playing with air and he's going out
there and I mean he will play well I
mean we seen him you know against the
bear stand in the pocket and throw the
ball around now we got a better defense
coming in there I'm sure Zimmer is not
just gonna let you stand back there and
throw it and throw the ball he's gonna
bring some heat after you so I'm sure
he'll have some plays and little hot
routes and justments and stuff for that
but he's definitely going out there he's
just that type of guy
he don't like missing games and he's
gonna go wow also it's this is it I mean
the NFC North is up for grabs between
these two teams one would think based on
what we saw with the Lions and how they
looked on Monday Night Football I know
it's just one week and but the Bears
look improved mm-hm and to continue on
and take that next step and hand the
Vikings their first loss of the season
certainly when it's in your house I
think for sure he's going to be out
there but interesting how you say that
Zimmer is not just gonna let him sit
back there the Bears hit Khalil Mak yeah
and playing it's an absurdly high level
how what happened in the second half but
at the same time the Bears didn't bring
no no heat after and they didn't bring
no blitzes so you're expecting a
four-man rush to get there like it was
getting there you know in the first half
within the second half the Packers came
out they started getting some help on
Khalil Mak chipping and bringing an
extra tight end over there blocking him
giving Aaron Aaron some more time and
they never brought any bliss they just
sat back in his own
cannot sit back in a zone on errand so
we all know zimmer a lot of exotic
blitzes trying to trick you so I'm sure
he'll bring some of that stuff after
Aaron and Aaron's familiar with him you
know I mean it's the vision opponent so
so he'll be ready but yes you're exactly
right rich you got to go out there this
is really for the division I mean you
want to get a game up on a division
opponent like the Vikings if Buffalo was
coming to town then maybe arrest you
he'll let the shaman Kaiser go out there
but this is a division game and you need
to get this one yeah you got a whole
surf on home games in the division
certainly against the team that that
that is the defending champs in your
division and that team is the one that
knocked you out last year literally
physically all of them you know that's
in the back of his mind is it do you
think I think so man he's a competitive
kid you know I mean so he he definitely
remembers what happened you put me out
you know Minnesota Vikings I'm coming
back and you know we're gonna we're
gonna see who the best in north now
James Jones here on the Rich Eisen show
it does uh as there any lingering
resentment you think in the Raiders
locker room over the Khalil Mack trade
um from watching that game and it being
the fourth quarter with six minutes left
and you have Todd Gurley in your
backfield and you're up by 10 points and
your play-action passing as an often
sitting over there I'm knowing they are
now play-action pass and if we got a guy
like a lil Mac coming to get the
quarterback
Jared golf was standing back there with
a cup of coffee just standing up there
all day you had one hour to quarterback
hits one sack you know you better
believe that they're talking in that
locker room like man we let a guy go out
like a lil Mac that a lot of production
and we just we just let him walk I'm not
gonna say for nothing because I don't
know what we're gonna get out of these
first two right pick but a team that
kind of felt like they were built to win
now and you let your best player go you
better believe that they talking amongst
each other in the locker room like that
bad move especially I don't know if the
the quote you're gonna talk about a
little bit more I think in your news
update Chris right but unpack it what
Gruden talked about about the the pass
rush yeah you see that yeah you want the
full quote just give me just to give the
law basically he said they needed to get
after the passer more and he's what we
got it we got a little we're gonna look
in July
why there was no pass-rush we're gonna
look into walking I think we all know -
why yeah and he also told Lisa Salters
that it was obvious that Mac didn't want
to be there would you agree with that
absolutely not I was I was actually
talking just in a Total Access meeting I
was saying I was there when Khalil got
drafted I played with Khalil one year
and to me that right there is what
that's how you lose a locker room
because Gruden you've never met Khalil
Mack all these guys in the locker room
have been with Khalil Mac for five years
four or five years so they know the type
of teammate he is unbelievable teammate
I remember when we were oh and ten his
rookie year Derek ours rookie year and
every time we came in the meeting room
all the coach show was plays a Khalil we
down by 40 look at this guy balls to the
wall hundred miles per hour going after
every single play so his teammates
notice so when you hear a comment like
that that that may as a teammate that
makes you mad cuz you know the type of
guy Khalil neck is an ass the type
that's the fastest way you could lose a
locker room in my opinion so what do you
think happens here I mean the Raiders
are our Owen one we saw that they've got
a game at Denver this week division
contests on the road what do you think
von Miller's coming down the pike I mean
it's close to a facsimile of Khalil Mack
as there is you could make a case it's
the other way around max the facsimile
of von Miller
um I know it sounds crazy but I'm still
a believer in the Raiders cuz I mean I
believe Derek Carr is gonna be a star in
this league you know I mean he had a bad
game but I believe he's gonna be a star
in this league
I believe you turn around and you hand
the ball off to Marshawn Lynch more
there's average of four yards a carry
you know so I think you give him the
ball more and I think Gruden is gonna
find ways to win some ball games but
whenever you have a good quarterback and
I believe Derek Carr is gonna be special
you got a shot so we still gotta wait to
see I mean they ran into a great defense
week one that's always hard when the
offense is trying to trying to figure
out who they are and then you run into a
big-time defense so I'm still the
believer in the Raiders I think they
could find a way to get to get it done
and
and get some wins James Jones here NFL
Total Access tonight at 7:00 Eastern
Time on the NFL Network with James and
cast of thousands what what's the answer
for the Cowboys offense do you think
it's not good that your reactions that
is just to laugh but what do you think
the answer is here they are an answer
they need a receiver and I think his
name is Dez Bryant you got a guy that
knows your office come in right now he
knows all the signals you don't gotta
pay him what he was making when he comes
in to me and you let him know this is
how it's supposed to go look dak is our
leader don't come in here trying to you
know out lead a can be the leader on the
office deck as our leader we just want
you to come in here be dad's make some
plays you're gonna get one-on-one
coverage they put eight in the box on
Zeke let's make some place because right
now we don't have that guy you know the
Carolina Panthers put eight in the box
that couldn't make no one-on-one throws
and beat no one-on-one coverage and
throws receivers open I think you need
to bring in a guy like Dez Bryant who
can beat the one-on-one coverage and
make plays
he dropped nine balls last year if he
don't drop those nine balls he has over
a thousand yards and he's still a cowboy
you know so it seems to say if you bring
him back and he doesn't drop them balls
he's still gonna forgive you some great
production and he can beat one-on-one
well you hear wouldn't people you hear
what people say though James that that
he might be a little bit too
in-your-face foredeck and that in that
it's a more doc friendly environment
without him there but it's about winning
the doc friendly environment and then
you go out there to Carolina and you
look like that it's about winning Jerry
Jones wants to win he's Cowboy fans
wants to win and I think you need a guy
a big-time receiver out there to make
some place he doesn't have that so
they're gonna continue to see eight in
the box
dad can you beat us and I don't know if
dak is that guy I could throw the ball
around a fitting Beach before we send
James up the 405 to the NFL Network
headquarters asking the poll question
Chris Brockman yeah James
well can I love you on bail situation
with the Steelers what should they do
with him wait it out up the money on the
franchise tender or trade him up the
money on the franchise
tender I mean you can't trade I mean I
don't think it's a team out there I
would come and trade for him because you
gotta realize okay what you're gonna get
them for 15 games cuz you still got to
pay him a long-term deal so I
wouldn't trade him I would up to
franchise tender get him in there let's
play I know the young kid Connor had a
great game but there is no levy on bills
out there I mean this is this is a once
in a generation type player but what I
want to get him in the bill but you know
what management's like I mean put
yourself in their shoes if they go ahead
and say okay here's more money on the
tender come in mm-hmm
what about the next time what about
somebody else well hopefully they can
give them more money on the tender and
then going to free agency next year and
getting paid I mean I I don't understand
how the best running back in the
National Football League can't get paid
why can't you find a way to get this guy
paid with him on the field you guys can
win the Super Bowl and that's what it's
about especially in Pittsburgh they used
to win it you could win the Super Bowl
with him not there I don't think you
could go through that AFC and win the
Super Bowl yeah you got Big Ben you got
a B but without this kid there you
cannot win the Super Bowl so let's bring
him in raise his money bring him in this
year let's go win the Super Bowl we'll
worry about the contract and in offices
and then our other Twitter poll that
we've put out there because I I can't
stand here and then just one weekend the
Giants should regret passing on Sam darn
'old and the Browns as well you know
Berkeley is no yes he's no just like off
the turnip truck here okay he's awesome
he's generationally talent absolutely
okay
so that said Josh Allen named the
starter this week which rookie thinks
gonna have a more impressive week to say
qualm Sunday night the Giants Darnell
did home against the Dolphins or Josh
Allen's first career start against the
bills a Quan I think say Quan against
the Cowboys he is gonna have a huge game
out there I feel the same way yeah he
don't have a he's gonna have a huge game
I mean to go over a hundred against the
Jacksonville Jaguars defense then you
going to Dallas I think I think you
could see him easily over 150 was a Jets
absolutely and he's using heave he's
that good to step into the spotlight
when it's expect and you got to realize
too you can't load the box on him you
have oh Dale you have Sheppard you got
Ingram they'll pick you apart if you
load the box so he's gonna have these
six boxes and all that and the type of
player he is one hundred and fifty two
touchdowns my prediction will check on
the results as
our app in our Twitter account after
this but for the moment thanks for
coming here not a problem let's keep
doing this absolutely the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience